most guests very professional Malin
Akerman showed up on time yeah you were
running a little late today I did run
along I gotta bring it up in front of
people cuz that's not professional
what's going on why did you do that like
you were because I make it a piece of I
buy every day like you were critiquing a
linguine right now we're just chatting I
was a little late it was my fault you
guys sent a car and then I told the
driver this is controversial I know not
to use Waze does anybody know what
waze's I use Waze
you like ways ways tells you how to get
it's the app that tells you how to get
there the fastest I entered yes that's
the idea
does anyone here hate ways I screw ways
it is not the way of the soul Conan what
are you talking all head get off the
main road left right left right I'm
beating the system no I do not need to
save five minutes careening through
gated community we don't belong there
the last time I use Waze I ran over a
skateboard people that liked it but why
isn't there we can all agree there
should be a medium setting right it's
either off or Indiana Jones it's like no
help whatsoever thinks you're rushing a
kidney to the Obama family tell me if
there's something I need to know about
you no I don't want to know
get on the ten surrender get on the
freeway just get them every way long
slow straight good be alone with your
thoughts listen to a podcast call a
friend keep a friendship alive where are
you going yeah you can come to work five
minutes early I see these people in my
office
sweaty panicked for making all the
suicide left's on the floor on
I'll be three minutes late and tell
everyone what I learned on this American
I hey good point it maybe it works in
Arkansas
you